Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
This is the fifth episode of clustered,
a show in which we have two Kubernetes
clusters broken by members of the community,
and we will try to fix them live.
Now before we get started and I introduce
my guest for today,
I'm gonna remember to do my housekeeping.
So
please remember, we have a Discord channel. Come
and join us in the chat. Right now,
we are giving away a cluster t shirt.
All you have to do is join a
cluster channel and thumbs up on the contest,
and you'll have a chance to win. The
prize should be drawn in roughly one hour.
Also, remember to subscribe to us on YouTube
and text that bell. That helps other people
find their content.
And I wanna thank Equinix Medal, my employer.
They donate bare
metal, the resources, and the time for me
to do this.
As much as I hate it and enjoy
it at the same time, I've gotta thank
them. It's a pleasure.
Alright. Let's crack on. Today, I am joined
by a friend and colleague, Jason DeTibbers. Hey,
Jason. How are you?
Hey. Thanks for having me. I'm doing well.
So for those who don't know me,
my name is Jason.
I've been involved with Kubernetes now for, oh,
wow,
about six years now.
Been doing mostly
cluster life cycle management
and
trying to help people get Kubernetes clusters.
So it should be fun to help try
to rescue some broken ones. It's been a
while since I've had to troubleshoot and and
fix live clusters.
Yes. Yes. Definitely. I think that your experience
is gonna be fantastic today with all the
the things that you've done in the Kubernetes
community and the projects that you've worked on.
It's like I'm hoping
we're we're gonna sail through this in the
record time. That's what I'm hoping for today.
Okay.
Let's see. We have two great clusters today.
Our first cluster was broken by Thomas Stromberg,
a name that people from the Kubernetes community
may be familiar with. He is responsible
for the mini cube project
and
has set a little bit of fear into
my life today.
I'm gonna pull up a tweet.
Oh, scroll, scroll, scroll. There we go.
Thomas was concerned that the break was too
breaky if that's the thing and
isn't actually sure if we'll be able to
fix it, but I'm hoping we can surprise
him a little bit here. So let's crack
on that and Thomas has joined the chat.
There we go.
Thomas is a horrible goose. Yes. Thank you.
We're excited excited
to tackle this one.
Alright.
Let's see. Let's pull up my screen share.
We should have a shared teleport instance. We
use Teleport to, commoditize access to the server,
and, hopefully, it means that Jason and I
can share a terminal. Let me remove the
Discord chat for now.
Alright. Jason, you should be able to join
the session by going to active sessions and
clicking join.
We hope.
And feel free just to type a echo
hello if you can.
Yep.
Let's see.
That's me.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
Hey. Nice. Okay.
So we both have a shared terminal. Our
cluster is a single control plane. I have
learned that now after four episodes, three episodes
that I don't wanna replicate my fixes to
three different cluster nodes.
Although we do still have
three Oh, there's only two worker nodes here.
I wonder if one of them is dead.
We're gonna find out.
So what would you like to do first,
Jason? What do you wanna check?
Well, I think the first thing we should
probably do is try to see if we
can reach the API server and go from
there.
So
and it looks like we do not have
access. So
Go figure.
That's at least telling us something. We're already
on the control plane machine, so we don't
have to move to a different host.
So we're using container d here. So I
can do a a CTR
namespaces because I can't remember exactly what the
namespace
is for Kubernetes,
and it's kates dot I o.
And I don't have tab completion, but
I'm just gonna reload that. That's that weird
thing. We're good.
And I So I've never used the ctr
command before.
I think I can do c l s
to look at all the containers in there.
Now, alternatively, I could probably use
the
I don't even know how you would pronounce
it. The c r I c t l
tool,
which would let us see pods.
Okay. So we have an API server that's
not responding.
Would you not just use p s? Is
there an added value to maybe going through
the CTR command?
Yeah. I mean, I I think
probably not. I mean, either way would work.
Normally, if it was a docker based host,
I'd just do a docker p s and
and go from there, and then docker logs
to get the logs for the host.
Okay.
Alright. But Cool. We can do a p
s. That'll work.
It helps if I grep. Right?
No API server.
Do we have an etcd?
It looks like we at least have etcd.
Oh, I see something very suspicious already with
a a whale a
whale true there.
Yes.
So I mean, I'm I'm does it we've
seen that?
I'm assuming we can just go ahead and
kill that. We probably don't want that to
be running. Right?
Yeah. Probably not.
So
let's go ahead and Thomas has commented and
says that cry control is crying cuddle,
which is I think is our advice for
today.
Alright. That at least got rid of that.
We'll see if it responds again at least.
Yeah. So I think that was just killing
EdCT. Anyway, I don't think it was
Yeah. And we can see EdCD there, so
that's good.
Yep. The other thing we can do is
we can also look at the kubelet logs
as well.
And that's because the kubelet is responsible for
spinning up through static manifests all of the
control plane controllers. Right?
Exactly.
So in this case, we can see that
there's
a crash back off loop.
Failed to get status for
cube API server,
TLS handshake time out.
That's not too surprising there.
We've got quite a lot going on here.
So I I think
So should we take a look at the
look at logs. The API server logs. Right?
Yeah. Let's go there. Okay.
I
think they get output to the bar log
somewhere.
Duffy is suggesting we restart the kubelet and
I'm I'm not falling for that one again.
It caused me more problems than than it
fixed last time.
What do we have here?
We got cube API server.
Oh, I think I need to reload again.
Oh, no. You were just looking at tab
completion. Okay. That does That's not shared.
Alright. Hey.
So does that mean it's unable to speak
to etcd?
I see a context. Cd speaking to local
host two three seven nine. Remember right that
it's the etcd ports.
It is. So we can probably go there
to s c d.
Alright.
And we have fixed s c d, so
I guess we just need to either wait
or hurry up a little bit.
So
looks like we have
two logs here.
I'm guessing at one point, we had multiple
containers.
Oh, that's good.
Yeah. That one looked good.
At least no obvious failures.
So the only error we've seen in API
server logs was the the context design for
etcd.
Etcd was broken by, we think, the infinite
sleep or well true sleep kill, which we've
stopped.
Should we just be should we just check
the API server's running again?
We can.
One of the other things, because we saw
that not being able to connect to twenty
three seventy nine, we can just do a
netstat and see
if we're actually listening there. And it looks
like we are.
I don't see a 2379,
do you?
Oh, I guess.
I I scrolled up, but I guess we
don't share the same scroll button. No. We
don't show the Yeah. Oh, yeah. Okay. Yeah.
It is there.
Cool. Looks good.
So we at least have an etcd port.
We can go ahead and take a look
at the API server logs again, or we
can see if there was a second container
there too.
Alright. Whatever you think is best.
Alright.
It looks like there's only
the one there.
So if that was in a crash lit
back off rather than like
It probably just hasn't
Yeah.
There'll be some sort of exponential back off
on that one there. So can we
we encovage it?
Yeah. I should be able to just touch
the file in here. But
since I have watched an episode or two
before before I touch it,
it doesn't hurt to take a look at
the the time stamps here.
And it looks like the time stamps are
relatively normal, so it's not gonna hurt to
touch it.
Now.
Thomas is dropping us a small hint. He
says, it's listening, but does it answer?
We may have to dust off our
Telnet command or something or etcd commands. I
need to pull up my my famous cheat
sheet that I keep borrowing.
So we don't have
We don't have etcd
cuddle installed.
We should be on an Ubuntu host here.
I don't know if it's prepackaged for Ubuntu
or not. Etcd dash claim.
That'll work.
Yeah. I've done that a few times now.
If I can.
Something a little bit effy was a networking
here.
And the plot seconds.
So we have connectivity,
but we don't have DNS that appears. Hold
on. Someone said there's always DNS. I need
to I need to pop that up there.
Well, he's he was in early with that.
There we go.
Well, that's an interesting
name server that we have there. Yeah. I
think we could probably just drop that out
for 8.8.8.eight.
And I know some people are probably screaming
at the screen because I don't remember my
VI short code short codes to do things
like delete stuff.
Do you wanna try curling Google or yeah.
I'll ping Google. There we So
we have that.
K. So
that wouldn't have
I think that was just yeah. Luck that
we found out trying to do an update.
That won't be our NCD problem, so we
still need NCD control.
Do you want me to grab the cheat
sheet or are you have you got this?
If you have the cheat sheet handy, let's
go ahead and use that. Otherwise, I'm gonna
be
fighting with the I really need to bookmark
it at this point I feel just because
I use it so much,
but these are the way my favorite. I'm
gonna put this on the show notes actually.
I keep forgetting to do that. So if
I just, if I just paste this,
So that last command was the etcd get
Kubernetes.
So we can speak to etcd.
I'm not sure if that mumbo jumbo is
what we wanna see though.
I don't remember there being
UTF or binary values there.
Well, so a little while back,
native Kubernetes
resources were switched to
a more binary protocol. So the native Kubernetes
resources aren't stored in JSON. The
only CRD resources should be stored in JSON
and etcd. So it don't surprise me to
see
kind of funkiness from from the result.
Okay.
And we got a
comment from Duffy,
suggests that the running containers will probably still
be have an old copy of that DNS
as well. Something for us to keep in
mind if we just get further along.
So it probably wouldn't hurt to go ahead
and
touch all of these and
that should trigger the cubelet to
pick those up.
Okay. So I
we got etcd configured with the cheat sheet.
We've confirmed that we can query etcd, so
I'm not sure of that comment from Thomas
about it's
lessening but not answering it. It looked to
me like it did answer.
I wonder if we have an API server
running. Like,
should we check?
Ta da. And
yeah.
So that's progress.
So should we try running get nodes?
Let's go ahead. Why not?
Hey.
So there we go. We only had the
two worker nodes in teleport, but we have
three here. So
it looks like one of those isn't accessible
to teleport for some reason, but it does
appear at least
superficially healthy
here.
Alright. Let's see we can find any other
symptoms. You wanna run a get pods on
the cube system namespace.
See if things are
happy, we'll try and schedule a workload and
then maybe maybe we're fixed.
Oh, no. We got our CCM off. Hello.
That's
happened a few times now. I don't know
if that Thomas, let us know if that's
intentional or something else.
So this could be related to the DNS
configuration.
So I wouldn't
get too worried about that yet, but we
can just look at the logs and see
what we get there.
Not longs.
So we got a question from William in
the chat. What did the touch star command
cause?
So,
apparently,
if we touch the files in the static
manifest directory, the kubelet will
notice the change and then restart
those
pods for us. Is that correct?
Yes.
Exactly. So
what it does is,
basically, the kubelet looks in the static pod
directory,
and whenever it notices any change, it tries
to reload it. And if things are running
healthy
after it reconciles, you should see a mirror
pod for it,
which are the pod resources that we see
here. But it's the kubelet that actually controls
anything defined in the static manifests.
Cool. Perfect.
So our DNS is still broken in the
CCM.
Should we just start restarting stuff now that
we've fixed the DNS configuration on the host?
I think so. So
the cloud controller manager is a deployment.
So what we can do is basically
do a
a rollout of the deployment to kinda restart
things.
Yes. That's such a nice way of doing
it. I I tend to just kill all
the pods.
Keep control, delete dash l, label selector,
off you go.
Normally, have tab completion
and because I don't set it up very
much, I'm going to look at how to
re enable it here.
We could set up that. I think you
can do kubectl complete yeah. And then source
that into the
completion and then bash.
And then you can source that. It's a
little big sub shell. Yeah. Cool.
Oh, you'll the sub shell will be the
source. Yeah. We should be okay with just
the sub shell, I think.
Will that work? Yeah. No.
Or do we have to do a source
and then
dash
for standard and
or redirect it in?
Oh,
I feel like I'm failing basic Linux knowledge
test here. Yeah. Me too.
Yeah. Try that.
Okay. I've got the I've got the docs.
I've got the docs. Kubernetes
completion
source bash.
Yeah. There's the docs.
Oh, you have to do echo
source. Yeah.
You want me just to copy this?
Oh, sorry.
Oh, we got it. There we go. We
got it twice in there. Alright.
Thank you.
I see Duffy in the chat with the
with the help.
Oh, yeah. There's a while it's saying no
sub shell, and then Duffy got the command
as well.
Cool. Alright.
Is it working now? Yeah.
I gotta remember cube system.
Something weird with the control codes that they
are all complete only
goes to you, I think.
Need to send that to the teleport team.
We want that fixed.
Well, core DNS isn't very happy either.
So
before we continue with the controller manager, we
or the cloud controller manager, we probably wanna
take a look at DNS.
Kube system.
Okay.
That wasn't very helpful, No. It was not.
Is it running? Can you see it on
PS? Like, I don't know if it's just
not ready. Is it and it's running but
failing? Like, I'm not really sure what
session it's in at the moment.
Let's do a rollout of core DNS because
it might actually be affected by the DNS
issue.
Okay.
And
it's been a while since
I gotta give it a restart. That's why.
And I gotta give it
Oh,
it'll be
And I forgot the namespace.
And
we still don't have anything there.
So it's running. It's just not passing its
probe, which means the service won't be adding
the endpoints.
Do we wanna
check the probes?
Let's take a look at those logs one
more time.
I don't think we have enough time to
go through all those logs.
Yeah. That might take a while.
One of the things that I didn't think
about is is
we fixed the local
DNS issue,
but you can also set DNS policy on
the deployments as well.
So should we take a look at the
manifest for core DNS here? See what we're
doing with it? I think so.
So,
here we have this.
Well, I need to scroll up because we're
Yeah.
I just sat back letting you do all
the work, but that's that's not gonna work
now. Okay. Let's see.
I'm always really bad for going through this
too quickly and not actually paying attention. So
I'm gonna focus this thing.
So the liveness probe is set for slash
health on port 8,080.
I don't know if that's correct. We might
need to check that.
And there's a dash red. Oh, the readiness
probe is 8181. I don't think those will
be on different port numbers.
So should we you
should maybe try and check that, and I'm
just gonna scan for anything else.
I think
everything else okay. So I'm gonna assume that
one of those
probes is on the wrong port, which is
causing it not to add the endpoints to
the service.
That is definitely a possibility.
And
my default here is
basically to look at the code because
that's how I've learned
quite a bit about
troubleshooting clusters,
especially
in the case of
lack of documentation in the early days. So
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna look
into the manifest code that we actually deploy
from
Cube ATM.
Well, I've pulled up a random manifest
from the Internet or from the core DNS
organization though, and those reports are are correct.
They do run health and readiness on different
ports.
Interesting.
That is true. Code never lies.
You just gotta make sure that you're looking
at the right code sometimes.
The other thing that we have too is
we have the DNS policy default,
which default is not actually the default DNS
policy, if I remember correctly.
Where did you see that? Sorry.
In the Oh, here. Yeah. Deployment config. Yep.
So what does the default DNS policy mean
here?
I have to look.
It it's been a while, and I remember
it being confusing.
So what I'm doing is I basically just
googled for
documentation around it.
See if I can see Default is not
the default DNS policy.
If DNS policy is not explicitly configured,
then it's
usually used as cluster first.
And you also have cluster first with host
net
when you need something with host network set
to true. We don't actually core DNS doesn't
use host network, so that's not an issue.
Okay. So the default policy uses a node
DNS configuration, which makes sense for core DNS.
Right? That probably is
correct
since core DNS is providing the end cluster
DNS.
Quite possibly. And and I'm going into the
kubeadm code just to
verify at this point because that's
just what I do.
Yep.
And I'm looking at the deployment on the
core DNS organization and they do have a
DNS policy of default. So I'm I'm inclined
to think that's maybe alright.
I'm gonna
I'm gonna type stuff just because I'm not
sure what else to do.
So if we don't get services,
we've got kubed n s. I'm assuming if
I describe that, we're just gonna see no
end points.
So
Yeah. Okay. So
we need to work out why
Oh, I'm gonna alias that in a second.
Alias k equals.
Oh, okay. Weird stuff going on with our
CCM as well, but we'll come back to
that later.
Yeah. One is effective, the one is pending.
But I k. Core DNS. Where can we
get more logs from Core
I don't think there's another source of logs
for CoreDNS outside of the pod logs.
Outside of checking the manifest, we can also
check the config map as well
because it gets its configuration from the config
map.
Nice.
Had we not run get pods yet? That's
We did not.
Alright. So what I want you At least
not in the default namespace.
Yeah. What I want you to do is
jump inside one of these and actually try
and use the deck command against score DNS
to see if we're getting any responses.
But we
we can't do that from anything here.
Okay. Do we have anything running? Yeah. We
must have some stuff running.
Alright.
I'm pretty sure core DNS is distroless or
scratch, so I can't actually get inside of
that.
Are any of these other ones gonna be
able can I exec in any of these?
Do you know off the top of your
head?
Not off the top of my head. I
don't think etcd
is, but I could be wrong there as
well.
And I finally got to the manifest for
core DNS.
I got him one of the cube proxies,
but we've got the same DNS problem that
we have there. And I'm kinda worried right
now if that if we try restarting any
of these ones that are running,
they're probably not coming back
based on what I see in the default
namespace on our CCM.
So what's what are you thinking just now?
So I'm still looking and just comparing against
the
the manifest
for that's laid down by
Cube ATM.
And so far it looks like everything lines
up pretty well.
I guess,
could we port forward to core DNS and
use that locally to see if we're getting
a response. Is that worth doing just now,
or is there something else you wanna chase
down?
Let's go ahead and
do that
outside of well, actually,
I wanna double check the core file real
quick just because
So is that mounted then as a config
map?
Yep. It is.
It doesn't look like that's been modified though
because the age is
Yeah. But I don't think the age shows
you updates to it.
I think we ran into that before.
I'm looking forward to all these clusters being
one twenty one and never seen managed fields
again.
Right.
So we got the core file,
port 53,
errors health.
So I put But it looks like that
health has been modified.
Oh, did you lose your session?
I did not.
I'm not sure if something destructive has just
happened, but
there's no active sessions,
and I cannot start a shell.
Is your is your session still good?
Yeah.
I'm still connected here.
You need to run double check. Run a
command?
That's funny.
It's it's also still showing no active sessions.
Yeah. No. I can still run a command
and everything. So this is
But we can go ahead and rejoin.
Well, I guess we can't because No. I
can't. Do you wanna try starting a new
one and I can maybe join that?
Oh, I I don't know.
Oh,
alright. I'm seeing an active session now, it
seems.
And that says it's only a few seconds
ago.
Oh.
So Thomas is gonna fix that.
Apparently,
the resource exhaustion went too far. So something
they've configured in our cluster.
And, yep, there there have been disconnected
as well. So yeah.
I guess we'll wait a moment.
I think there's been a proper proper breakage
happened on this machine. I didn't even think
to check what was going on. Although, I
wonder if that recursive honk pod we've seen.
I wonder if there was something moving on
there. Maybe I should have checked the CPU
utilization or
So
I'll cover some of the rules.
Carlos has asked seem
to be able to connect to
Teleport at all now.
Carlos has asked if there's cron eating resources.
Yeah. One of the things I said I
won't do on this show is is look
at the cron so people could use it
in creative ways. And so I'm not sure
what's going on there,
But maybe we can Maybe Thomas will maybe
get us back in.
Oh, it's it's it's gone.
Yeah.
Alright.
So Thomas says problem
with SSH is not being able to share
the session.
Alright.
Let me pop open a terminal.
IP address.
No. Right. So I'm gonna just quickly debug
what's going on from a normal terminal and
see if can get teleport working again. Let's
see if we can deal with that.
Oh, SSH is not working.
Thomas is just laughing there.
Alright.
Let's move on to the second cluster just
now, and then we'll try and come back
to this one.
If I can't SSHN for the terminal,
I don't think there's much we can do
right now. So will we jump over to
Cluster 10?
Yes. I'm working on trying to
re log in to the teleport session there
right now though.
Okay.
This
is.
This one looks okay.
Oh, I've got a terminal open.
I'll cover the basics just now if you
wanna just take a minute to get in.
I'm pretty sure I'm not getting my victory
beer today.
I have a nice
rhubarb custard server.
There
we go. Show people.
Yeah. Thomas,
if you can SSH in, try and get
us back in the game, please. Otherwise,
destroyed it.
Which is very funny. I guess we took
too long to fix it.
That's funny.
Thomas does that. I guess it's my turn
to debug what the hell is going on.
Alright.
So
alias k equals kube control
export kube config equals
our control plan.
Get
notes. Okay. We have no API server. Go
figure standard
practice now.
Did you manage to join the session at
all? Or are still having a little bit
trouble there? I am joining it at this
moment. Alright. Cool. So I'm gonna do some
basic checks. I'm gonna look for the API
server.
No, but
I do love the watch cat command, so
I'm gonna take a w w on this
so we can see the build.
Why did that not show me the full
thing? Oh, this must be a teleport bug.
Oh, and the watch has disappeared now.
Oh, I saw it though. It's coming back.
Oh, right. Okay. I missed my opportunity to
see what that command was.
Okay. We have no API server.
What else do we need to check for?
Qubelet.
Okay. So we do have a running Qubelet.
Let's do the
same
thing.
Kubernetes
manifest.
We have fails that have been modified and
we have what loosely
I even remember what uses tilde backup fails,
nano maybe.
So now we know this cluster is broken
by Lewis, Dan and Patty, organizer of CloudNative
Wales
and and a little assist
from the control plane team. So I'm looking
forward to fixing this one. Thomas, we will
come back to your cluster in a minute.
Thomas has said that Teleport is back online.
I'm actually wondering if
they they made this one a little easy
for us by those tilde files actually being
the originals
looking at the time stamps and the
and the size differences.
Alright.
We'll be trying to fix this one in
quickly, or do you wanna go back to
nine while it's still fresh in your head?
I'll let you to save. We can go
ahead and jump back to nine and then
Right. Okay. Come back to this one. We
haven't gotten too far in, but it looks
like I'm gonna have to try to log
back into the Telescope session there too.
And do I have a session? I do
have a session. Thank you, Thomas.
So
kindly shared the error with us as well.
Runtime error, invalid memory address or no pointer.
Yeah. You definitely broke it.
Okay.
So
it's only been like two minutes and already
I have no idea what I was doing
with this cluster. So we
we got the API server back online, core
DNS wasn't running. There was all sorts of
crazy nonsense going on in I've lost my
alias.
The default namespace.
They say API server is down again.
Oh no, I've not got the export.
Okay.
You've joined, which means we have that weird
reload bug. Okay. So
should we just start I don't
all these things have fixed. Is this that
should have been indicative
of resource exhaustion. Things are being moved off
of this thing. That makes sense? So like,
we have top.
The load average isn't exactly revealing too much
there.
Let's check the memory. Oh, the memory is
there too.
So we don't have a lot used now,
but Yeah. We don't know what was happening
ten minutes ago, dude.
Exactly.
The other thing we can do is we
can look at
so far, I think we've only looked at
the default namespace, and we've only looked at
the cube system namespace.
So we can also look to see if
we have pods and other namespaces that may
be taking up resources.
Okay. So we wanna do an all namespaces.
That's a bit funny. Let's see if I
can maybe just make that a bit smaller.
Yeah. That helps. Okay. So Selium is running,
which I like.
Hubble's not.
I don't know what's going on with the
honks.
But they're all evicted anyway, so probably not
a problem.
I'm saying with a bit of hope rather
than any knowledge.
Our WordPress application
is not working. Core DNS is running, but
not healthy.
HCT is okay. APIs server is okay. In
fact, the control plane
besides core DNS appears to be alright. So
let's work out this.
Oh, no. Rawk is
dead in the water too.
Yep.
And
I I do like Thomas' suggestion of looking
at the eviction reasons,
so we can probably do a describe on
one of those pods to
and and get the the reason for the
eviction or or events.
Do you wanna as well. Take the controls
and they destroy it? Yeah.
So
so we know the honk ones are evicted.
But I
don't know if there's going to be any
type of a red herring there. So
You don't trust the one of the
WordPress ones.
K. Question for
mister Rawkode. Is this the first or second
cluster? It's the first.
Yes. We are back on the first cluster.
So I'm able to attach or mount volumes.
So which pod was this you described? Sorry.
This is the WordPress pod.
Oh, yeah. Those volumes won't be able to
able to mount because Rawkode is evicted as
well.
Yep.
So
Why don't we take a look at
I think you may you probably should describe
a honk. Let's just see what his talent
is. Yeah. Let's
So failed
to pull an unpack image.
Resolve failed.
Oh, yeah. That's using that old DNS entry
192168587.
So
that was the one that we fixed on
the load on the the machine itself.
But also,
there's another issue up here.
The node was low on resources on iNodes.
Ah.
Okay. So the resource exhaustion was iNodes rather
than memory or CPU.
So there's a couple of things
system could be configured with
a low number.
But just to double check that,
you know, it or it could just be
exhaustion on the actual file system device.
So we can look at d f has
a flag to show I node consumption. Right?
If it does, then I just learned it
today. Yeah. Because I've I've had this a
few times.
Yeah. Dash I.
Yeah. %
on a few things here.
Root fail system.
Now I don't know if that's gonna be
normal for an overlay root fail system to
show a % I node, but oh, and
there's our root file system actually.
It's run out of almost
run out of inodes as well.
And I wonder if that's So Sorry. I'm
gonna go.
Yeah.
So that would tell me there's a process
running
somewhere
open and fails.
Yeah. Would you agree with that?
Yes.
Alright. So we could use l s o
f to see if we see anything?
We can, but that's probably gonna be pretty
noisy as well because we are running a
system that's running containers.
Okay.
What's what's plan b?
So
I see
Thomas is suggesting
a d f command there.
Dash l root. You can go ahead.
I believe so. I'm having trouble
reading that small. But
And, yes, iNodes are not equal to open
files.
But they are part of the problem. Right?
I'm like, you either writing files,
opening file oh, maybe I'm failing miserably there.
Well, I mean, the files could already be
closed too.
But let yeah. Let's go ahead and do
well, we can do an l s on
various directories. We could do
we could try the l s o f
approach.
Okay. So we should
nothing in the root file system. So, you
know, it would have been helpful if it's
seen 65,000
files sitting there. But Exactly.
Okay.
What do you think that packer file is?
Should we just use the metadata? Like, if
we do a dash l,
see any timestamps that are recent.
No.
I mean, I'm tempted just to reach for
LSOF because I feel like I'm swinging though
for any idea.
So I know if we were looking at
actual file sizes,
I would use DU.
I don't know if there's a flag in
d u that would give us something
to look at inode usage.
I'm not aware of anything,
but we could do c tame.
I I don't know the find syntax that
well, but I'm sure we can do like
five days.
Create a time within five days. Is that
right?
Think so.
Fancy time. There is a way to do
it.
Google is my friend.
So he's given us a hint that it's
it was sitting right there in Oh.
In the root.
And d u dash I.
I
I forgot how to Linux.
Right.
D u dash d one. Oh, yeah. D
h.
Depth one and that will show me the
file sizes,
but not necessarily the nodes.
I think I caught something about the temp
directory there.
With this?
Yep.
Oh, yeah.
So you want to take a look in
temp?
I mean, four hundred and seventy four seventy
five megs does not look
because that stash l is taken taken time.
If you wanna consume
a lot of I nodes
and not consume
a lot of disk space, you're gonna write
a lot of really small files.
Yeah. Most of my
most of my commands I would use are
taking a very long time here.
Alright. Let's jump to the comments for help.
What have we got?
Is that a dot dot dot file?
Yes.
But I I can we can't run l
s in this directory.
At least not in
I'm not sure if that's ever gonna finish.
And that's a good point actually from
Thomas. Four hundred and seventy five meg is
huge for a directory. I mean, that's right.
Normally, I would always expect a directory just
to be four k.
So I've I've I I don't even know
what would cause that.
What causes that directory to be bigger? That
would tell me it's still a directory
or it's
something else? In fact, maybe is there something
on Well, the directory entry
has
a listing of all the
pointers to all the I nodes of the
files that are in there, doesn't it?
Right. Okay.
So Thomas has suggested to an echo star.
Nice.
Yeah. I'm almost kinda partial to taking the
RM approach.
Oh, the EchoStar has been
a terrible guess itself.
We should we should check the I node
exhaustion before
things get out of hand again.
Assuming I ever get the ability to write
to this terminal.
Yeah.
I'm gonna see if I can open a
new one. Let's see.
DFI.
And it still gets 35,000
I nodes, which is what was free previously.
So I'm assuming
that the
process in question has potentially been halted.
Do you wanna just
attempt deleting it?
Is that where we're at?
Yeah. Let's let's go ahead and
I like that. Thomas is feeling pity on
us and giving us a fine command to
help
clean it out.
That's assuming it can read enough off the
disk to make it work too.
Fingers crossed.
Guess we sit back and wait.
I I have a feeling that
there's a potential that those Honk pods may
be contributing to this. So even after we
clean this out,
we may see it come back.
Okay. We've we've also had a comment saying
d u can show I node exhaustion dash
dash I nodes. That's good to know. We
can try that in a minute.
Thomas not filling me with confidence after giving
us the command to help fix it as
I said, uh-oh.
Just another day.
Let's
do it. Okay. Let's terminal's back. So let's
try that flag that was suggested to us.
Alright. The fact that that's been out no
such fail, I think means the files were
being deleted as we ran the DU,
which is good. So hopefully that same command
is working.
And the syntax or the style of naming
on that temp makes me think that there's
a process running m k temp on a
loop.
That's the default file name, I believe.
So
we could just run.
Oh, look at that. We've got over a
million I nodes now and 89% usage.
So things are getting better.
Yes. Now, I guess our concern is
those Honk pods.
Are they gonna come back?
I I I like the comments right now
because he's suggesting that we go check out
DNS
while Find is running.
If you want to take over.
So that also tells me that
this is likely to refill up on us
again.
Ah, that's a good point. Like, if our
core DNS
wasn't if the deployment looked okay and the
probes were right, there's a reason it's not
responding to traffic, and it's probably that it's
not core DNS.
Is that potentially?
The image could be swapped out.
Yeah. We can go ahead and take a
look at that.
Oh, we're getting slow again.
So looking here,
we're looking for
Containers image.
Yep.
So that looks like an official image. I'm
not sure about the version. I think we
should change the pill policy to always just
to
we don't know how sneaky.
Yeah. Should we change that?
Nice.
Yeah. We can go ahead and change that
to always.
So
kubectl
edit
deployment,
cube system
for DNS.
Because that f not present means that Thomas
could have built their own image on the
machine running an MK template.
And just for
fun, I'm I'm also gonna double check the
so it looks like the latest version accordion
s is one dot eight dot three. So
I don't think one dot seven
seems unreasonable.
Yeah. And a good point from Wily as
well is we haven't even looked at the
core DNS config map yet. We got we
got very much sidetracked.
Yeah. I had started looking at that, and
I did notice that there was
the start of a diff there. So
So looking through, and I'm I'm comparing this
basically to the
kubeadm code right now.
So we have the config map, core file,
port 53,
errors. There's a difference in health.
So
so it's lame duck,
five seconds.
No comma there.
We're
also missing
ready, I believe.
Kubernetes
cluster dot local.
That looks the same. Pods and secure fall
through
TTL of 30.
And all of this, like I said, I'm
just pulling straight out of the code.
Hash 30
loop,
reload,
and load balance.
And maybe we'll get a working core DNS
again.
And gonna go ahead and do the rollout
because, generally, updating config map does not cause
a deployment to roll out an update.
So at this point,
they're still not running,
but that could just be We don't know
how long the probes need to be healthy
before.
Exactly. And the container's not even created yet.
Okay. So
little bit of patience to be exercised here.
I guess that pill policy of always, it
may just be pulling down the real image
now.
I didn't want the
grip in there.
So
looks like it's failing to create the pod
sandbox.
Failed to fill and unpack the pause image.
Indeed.
Is this still DNS? Oh, connection refused.
Trying to look up kates.gcr.i0
on
local port 53.
So what's the response is that container deal
responsible for pulling the images?
So
I believe it's a responsibility
of the cubelet to interact with CRI to
pull the necessary images.
So we're seeing
that we can go ahead and check the
container d configuration.
Yeah. I'm wondering if there's anything funny.
I don't know.
Touching it, draws.
And Thomas has suggested we take a look
at our resolve config again. Although, I'm sure
we fixed it.
Oh, no.
Is that a just in time hack? I
don't know what you're saying up there, Thomas.
Alright.
Well, let's get that 8888
back in there and get core DNS running.
I like how it modified it differently this
time.
See, that's what I don't like about it.
You wait to see if it's gonna change
again?
Hasn't yet, at least. Let's
yeah. There's something in cron. Okay. So since
we have permission to look in cron, even
though I said that I'll I won't look
in cron,
we can check out what's going on there.
So
Resolver, I guess. Either resolver.
Nice.
They're actually running every minute, so it's probably
already goosed again.
And I'm not over
familiar with running
Ubuntu as a host OS
to know whether those other
cron jobs in there are Let's cat them.
Let's see what's going on.
I mean, the Scrubble did not sound particularly
healthy.
That
doesn't seem
I don't know what you two scribble is.
Some sort of LDM thing. Yeah. We can
maybe just ignore it.
Do you wanna fix our resolve Conf again
and get let's check for DNS?
Because I'm assuming that we maybe got caught
by it. Yeah. There we go.
Before
we remove that.
Alright.
The rest are normal. Thomas has confirmed.
And then politely followed up with don't sweat
it. Thanks.
Alright. Let's see. Come on, Courtney.
Let's see if you're happy.
Oh, image pulled back off.
So that'll be that pulled back off.
So it could be a modified
tag version because not all core DNS versions
are tagged with the
Kubernetes release artifacts.
Or it could just be that
Nearing the finish line.
Yeah. So
why don't we just try and pull that
manually?
I guess I can always just pull it
from my local machine.
Or maybe we're just being impatient and the
back off happened during the DNS break and
oh, there we go. Let's pull it up.
Okay.
It's running unhealthy.
Perfect. So we have core DNS at this
point.
We have etcd. We have the API server,
and the controller manager and
scheduler are at least running from a pod
level, not necessarily
beyond that. But since core DNS is rescheduled,
I assume that the scheduler is actually functioning
here.
Yep.
So that should bring other containers online.
Now we still have the evicted
packet cloud controller manager, but that could very
well,
you know, be residual here.
So we can go ahead and restart that.
Shall we just grab one of the Honk
pods before they stick coming back?
Just one, this is called honk.
And what's it trying to run?
Busy box, well true, sleep, done.
Yeah. I don't think they're actually doing anything,
which is good.
For fun, let's do a get all and
see
thing here.
The pod just seemed to be sitting there.
I'd
let's take a look at the describe again
and see if there's anything indicating
Yeah. What created them. Still using that 182168587
DNS setting.
You wanna try a rule out on our
WordPress deployment and see if it's healthy?
Yeah. We can go ahead and well, first,
we probably need to check the
the status of our storage.
So that would be in Rawkode.
Okay. So one of the operators has come
back. One of the managers has also come
back.
I mean, we'll I I would just take
the sledgehammer approach here and do a delete
pod all namespace rick staff just to force
all that to come right back up.
Yeah. I got you to do one delete
all, which means that I
consider that a victorious stream.
And
hopefully, that gets our storage system back online,
then WordPress can come back online.
And I think that's it.
Fingers crossed.
Let's just see if we've got that coming
back here.
Oh, that was fun. I didn't even
Oh, you control c that's why. I did.
Get pods dash watch.
And the ordering will be important for a
lot of these just because of the way
that Rickettseth works.
I can see our
provisioner is just coming on.
Let's see what's running.
Yeah. I think this is gonna take a
minute or two.
Yeah. Cool. Okay. So let's assume our storage
system is gonna be online.
I delete all has never hurt anybody.
Yeah.
Making a lot of assumptions now though, so
let's see.
Hope is definitely a strategy when it comes
to clustered, I've found.
The thing was Yes. We still didn't remove
the honk pods.
I suppose we can go ahead and do
that.
They seemed harmless.
At least the first one we looked at
was just running asleep for a very long
time.
Wonder if he was kind enough to stick
a common label on it that we could
delete them all.
No.
No labels.
In fact, there was an anode message right
on that. We should have described that a
lot earlier.
Oops.
Want me to do some hockey magic to
delete all the honks?
Or we can do that. I'm also trying
to keep an eye out to see if
they start coming back too.
Carlos, there was no common label and no
owner ref. There was a straight up pod.
Evil, I know.
Oh, so we got a container created now
in one of our WordPress. That's exciting. And
one of the MySQL.
Although Rawkode isn't particularly looking much healthier.
Still sitting and pending on some of those
Mon and
Yeah. Instances.
Well, maybe we need to describe one of
those.
See why it's pending.
Let's grab the
oh, there's some tents on the notes.
So why doesn't give it, but we can
just do a describe on them. Yeah. Describe
note and let it all
All flooders.
Yeah. Locked through no execute.
Let me just do an edit nodes and
delete them?
Yep.
I
wonder if it's funny. Yeah.
Okay. Let's try.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, yeah. That's coming up much faster now.
There we go. Okay. So
And
maybe not too much movement quite there.
I see a container creating there on
Yeah.
Let's see if we're missing anything here.
No. Right. Okay. So everything on the Ceph
side is running.
I'm gonna try and speed up
this.
Well, it looks like it's been
creating for forty seven minutes now, so I
only wanna delete that one.
Yeah. So it it's not getting the volume.
PVC is those seem okay. Yeah. We can
probably just encourage that along.
Terminating.
So we might wanna do a describe on
that MySQL pod to see if we have
any new
information.
The volume is previously attached.
Was that just the terminating one now?
Yes.
Okay. So let's delete pod
force
grace period.
Should be quicker than that.
That is a good point. Is there an
are we supposed to have an NGINX
No. Out here?
Yeah. Let's just Wait a minute.
What was that one that you were just
describing?
That was nginx? The busy box one? I'm
just gonna delete it.
Get pods.
I don't know why we're in a multi
detach thing here.
I'm gonna try one more time to hurry
up.
Maybe we should Is
that still giving the same error?
Yeah. It was still saying it was attached
to another pod, which isn't scheduled anymore.
But I wonder if that's just collateral damage.
There we go.
Alright.
What's going on here?
I think this is just
a weird situation. Need to wait for things
to
I think we've fixed this cluster.
Will we move on to 10? You happy?
I
think I'd like to see that WordPress pod
still up yet, because I'm not entirely sure
there isn't another
another curveball that he's thrown at us here.
You just don't want me to have my
beer. That's Riz.
Alright. So the problem is, this week, a
standard is attached to another pod.
Thomas says he has no idea, so I
I don't think this is intended.
But it's still as a
problem. So it seems to think it's attached
to another pod.
So it can't be attached to another.
It's definitely not attached.
Alright.
No. The MySQL container is running.
The PVC on the WordPress one
isn't particularly important.
I could delete it.
Yeah.
Oh, wrong one. K a get PVC.
Delete
PVC.
That's the MySQL. Delete the WordPress one.
And then if we
encourage the pod to request a new one,
Hopefully,
that pending
changes.
Okay. So now
Oh,
we deleted the claim.
So now there's no claim for it to
to use.
Yes. Yes. We are teaching bad
practices at this point.
Well, no. The WordPress
WordPress doesn't actually need a persistent volume. It's
only for cache.
As I I I do not encourage anyone
to ever delete any real So
yes and no.
If if it was an actual running
WordPress instance, it would have deleted any of
the
file system assets that you upload.
If you upload any media content, that doesn't
go into the database. It goes onto the
file system.
Oops.
That that's one of the reasons why I
generally dislike the idea of
WordPress as, like, an example app for systems
like
Kubernetes
because it's really difficult to actually scale WordPress
horizontally for that reason. You need to end
up having
shared storage that can be mounted on multiple
places to be able to
actually access that content.
Thomas had no idea that we would help
him make the cluster even more broken.
You
underestimate me, Thomas.
Alright.
So at this point, we we likely
need to recreate a PVC claim for the
WordPress app.
Okay.
But I don't know exactly what that looked
like.
I have it on a disk.
Export.
Our PVC should be
workload.
Let's just pop this open.
There. Yeah. So let's just apply that over
the top.
Jump back over here.
We have our PVCs.
I guess I maybe need to
either be patient. Yeah. I was gonna say,
just delete the pod, but I'll be patient.
Yeah. It's just pulling the image now. Okay.
That looks much better. Alright.
So I never actually deleted any data. I
only did the claim.
The
preview is still there.
So that that worked. It's running.
You happy?
I
think so.
I I don't know that
I've seen anything else to indicate anything else
has been wrong at this point. And we
do have some encouragement to jump over to
Cluster 10.
Alright. Let's see. Okay.
Thank you, Thomas. That was painful.
Okay.
9 go away.
I don't even know if that's 10 anymore.
Let's
pop this open.
And I'm going to go ahead and try
to get logged back into teleport.
Come on, teleport.
Timed out.
Bad ass.
What?
That's not good.
Pull up the IP address for Cluster 10
in case something has gone wrong.
Was logged to this seeing a similar thing.
Yeah. I was logged on to this earlier.
Oh, it should be s.
That's for ten.
Alright. Let's see if we've got SSH access.
And I will restart.
Teleport.
There we go.
Alright.
Okay.
So we have our cluster. I believe I
already checked.
Someone ran a watch. I should know that.
Kubect config,
etcetera. Kubernetes
admin
Conf get node. Okay. So we don't have
a working API server. Are you on the
session? Just let me confirm. Yes. I joined
the session.
Okay.
So we can go ahead and look to
see if we have the API server
and probably etcd as well running at this
point since we can't actually connect to the
API server.
Okay. Etcd
looks good. API server
well, I mean, it's running. Doesn't mean that
it's good.
Okay.
I see a node restriction plugin right away
on the API server here.
What does what does that admission plugin do?
Do you know?
I don't know off the top of my
head, but we can look it up.
There's no restrictions that is dangerous.
Okay. So this admission controller limits the node
and pod objects that Kubelet can modify.
Okay. So that's not a big deal.
Alright. So let's go check out our manifest
directory.
We're assuming something has changed on our API
server.
It's running,
but when we do
We should just export it keep config and
stuff
before I start typing things I don't wanna
type.
I think we might be on separate sessions
at this point. What? Oh, no. I'm on
my actual sorry.
Okay.
I thought my terminal felt a little familiar
there.
Okay. So let's export config.
And if we run alias k qptl.
So it's trying to speak to the IP
address, which I'll assume for the time being
is this machine on 6443.
API server does appear to be running. So
if we check the manifest and make sure
the port hasn't been touched, I guess is
the first thing, and then
look at other things.
The other thing we can do is we
probably can do a netstat and see what
we're actually listening on too. Alright. Feel free
to tapey tapey.
It doesn't like me trying to get
alright.
Now I see the Kubelet, and I'm just
scrolling through here.
I see etcd.
I do not see
the API server.
So
Yep. But I don't see the API server
either.
So that one that makes me wonder if
we're not act if the manifest's been modified
so that it's not actually running with host
networking.
Okay. So should we pop up in the
manifest?
Yeah.
Did we just get Rickrolled?
I think we did. I think we did.
If I remember correctly from the last time
we were on this cluster,
there was a another file there
appended with a tilde.
But it's not the actual API server. It's
not the API server. I wonder if one
of the tildes is
the other one, but
no. That's actually a cube controller manager.
What's that etcd one look like?
Uh-oh.
Oh, I think that's just empty.
But I it's not popped up in Vim.
Or is it just my size that's frozen?
No. It's
Guess I'm reloading.
Oh, no. That session's no That that's gone.
Nice. And that fail.
Oh, it killed teleport.
Oh, god.
I don't have this session either.
So my normal SSH and my teleporter are
now both dead.
Oh, is it coming? I think teleports back
at least.
Yeah. Okay. So my SSH is there to
teleport that. Okay. So
etcetera Kubernetes manifest is a symlink.
They never got any.
And then
these
well, it's crashed again.
There's 44 files in this directory and did
an LSE.
Gonna be one of those days, Jason.
Alright.
So we know the ETCD manifest isn't happy
either.
And it's only
38 bytes.
Okay.
I don't know where to reload it.
Okay. So whatever we are doing is
pausing.
So that SSH session has come back. I'm
assuming teleporter is gonna be right behind it.
It's really peculiar.
I don't know where just to be patient
with it or prod or no. My SSH
session is
going to.
That
is a good point to see if it
is
overlaid.
This is what happens when you get security
people
to mess with your cluster.
Oh, and there's there's Ivan, a control plane.
I don't know what you call yourselves. Control
planer.
Okay. So I think teleport's back at least.
Is it? Let me oh, that session's gone.
Okay. Let's start. Are you in a different
session?
I did not start a session. Alright. Okay.
Okay. We have a new session.
Let's
be a bit more care I'm speaking to
myself there, not to you. Let's be a
bit more careful and not trust anything that
control plane have done to this cluster. Screw
you this. Alright.
So
I I didn't like that this was
a assembling and
was it no that suggested just removing assembling.
Correct?
Yes.
Oh, it froze on me again.
You get two people to break a cluster
and they both managed to break it so
much that we can't even debug it. I
mean
You know what? I'm cracking open this beer.
I've had enough.
Right.
Take six.
SSH still dead.
I'll try a new session.
I think teleport's hung up right now again.
Alright. We're back. Does that mean the session's
alive again?
Yes. Okay. Yeah. Alright. So I'm assuming we've
got a very fitting amount of time to
do something. So What you wanna do? We
do anything more, I I wanna just see
what's mounted on the system right now.
Good call. I'll drink my beer. You you
do what you have to do.
So
Thomas, we do have serial access if needed.
Yes.
It just means going through my standard SSH
tools instead of teleport, which I try to
avoid.
Session are you typing on?
I thought it was the same one and
I just typed mount to see what's going
on now on the system.
And I see quite a bit of rick
rolling happening.
Yes. We got a a lot of it's
just like a recursive
some link thing going on here. Over the
file system.
Quite interesting.
So
we can go ahead and just try to
start unmounting these. I'm not entirely sure that
they won't come back, though.
Well, maybe because
Alright. So what if we be frozen again.
Oh, we are frozen again. Oh,
come on.
How's your taping, Jason? This actually reminds me
of
an issue that I've seen in production.
Not
quite identical,
but
I I once had to deal with an
issue where
we would get traffic in at the same
time every day
once a week, and
we only had the window
a small window to actually inspect what was
happening.
Because once we hit the threshold of the
event,
it would lock up our entire network. We'd
have to restart
our main routers,
and then
we didn't have any more traffic until the
next week.
So it took us a couple of months
to figure out exactly what was going on
because we only had that, like, fifteen minute
window
one day a week to actually troubleshoot it.
And, like,
the limited time that we actually have on
here is reminding me quite a bit of
that.
Take that control plan.
And
I wonder if he'll come back.
I hope they've kept the scripts that set
this up. I need to be I need
to see what they did here.
Because Lewis sent me a message saying,
didn't really have a lot of time,
so you might be able to fix it
really, really quickly, but good luck. I
don't know if that was a joke or
or not anymore.
Hopefully, that's unmount.
I really hope it's working.
I don't even know. How many were there?
Hundreds? Thousands?
I I don't think there were hundreds. Alright.
Okay.
Millions.
And
teleporters.
Yeah. Don't think I again. I don't think
unmounted everything because I grabbed through never, so
it should have been quite targeted. However, they're
all busy, so this unmount has failed disastrously.
Worth a shot, though. What you got, Jason?
You're up.
So we can go ahead and
try to see if we can get in
an LSOF here to see what actually is
well,
we know that the static manifests are in
there.
So
So knows that there were no RX to
human
there were pass through XRX.
We should have been okay.
So with the static manifest in there, I'm
wondering
if we might need to actually
stop the cubelet before we can actually unmount
these.
Okay. So you wanna do a stop cubelet?
Yep. And let's go ahead and give that
another try.
We could also try passing it
the force flag as well.
Well, I can still type, so the system
hasn't locked up on us
again yet. But if you wanna control c
and try something, please feel free.
No. I think we should let it
go out.
Though I am
thinking about opening up a second terminal.
Looks like it's still busy, though. Yeah. Okay.
That didn't work.
We're hung again.
No. That's okay.
Yep. Are
we? Okay. Oh.
That
was most unfortunate
double type in the enter of return.
Interesting question from Carlos. I thought the task
was to break Kubernetes, not the operating system.
Well, in theory, practice, they have broken Kubernetes
through the operating system.
Well, this may not be a production outage
that you may necessarily face. Your clusters are
still susceptible to wild geese. So
It's
funny.
I'd be laughing more if I wasn't crying
on the inside.
Yeah. We're we're kinda struggling
with this one here.
So
on the other
session that I opened up, the LSOF
did start returning.
And I see there's at least a sleep
going on. I see a process
that looks to be rick rolling us as
well. Should we start killing some wild processes?
I have another session here as well. So
we just start seeing what we're looking.
Oh.
I I think we're gonna see a process
that is Rick rolling us as well.
Oh, my sessions are
or Alice or Wes finished as well.
Alright.
So
we do have the shell script here that
is running.
So I reckon we killed that.
Yep.
Are you okay with a Kelminus name, or
do you want me to?
I'd I'd think we can safely kill this
process
ungracefully.
Let's see if it comes back.
Not immediately.
Okay. Do we wanna take a look at
it and see what they've done?
Or just think that's a I'm
gonna go ahead and try to rerun that
LSOF in the other terminal.
While over here, we can potentially just try
the unmount again, but.
Yeah. Okay. Let's try the unmount again.
Nope. Still busy.
Still busy. But that returned quicker this time,
so that's something.
Okay. So we got some sleep processes running.
Never has not come back, though.
So the sleep processes could potentially just be
POS containers as well.
Yep.
And it's hard to tell how many of
those random best sessions are actually just us.
I think this looks
more sensible now.
But
we do still have the big crazy weird
mount thing.
And it looks like that process has come
back.
I've never
oh, I don't see it.
No. Oh,
okay. Never mind.
But we do
we do have
some shell somewhere
sitting out that is
in that
dot never directory.
Okay. So what do you wanna try?
So
I've got ten minutes before my next call.
Let's see if we can get this done.
So
there's a total of
four shell sessions open.
I'm assuming that's our
IPs.
I would expect so.
I think I'm the 8082.
So I think we can probably kill the
early ones here.
So 1824.
I can get it.
Having all sorts of problems with My teleport
gets a little bit Oh.
Did I?
Start a new session. I think I got
a little confused there.
Okay. So I think we need to
unmount
that stuff.
Okay. So we still don't have any APIs
ever. So let's let's try and get this
worked out.
So
those shells are still there.
Okay. Let's kill them.
Alright. Those are gone. We're now just got
this one shell,
which I think you might be on or
maybe not. I'm not sure.
Let's
Why don't we just try
So I think we're gonna have to remove
that SIM link.
Potentially, I have to remove that SIM link
too.
But we should still be able to unmount
it and it just be a broken SIM
link. It's
stalled on me again.
Still seem to be going.
Okay. So now we don't have a manifest
directory.
Alright.
We probably still need to unmount those.
So Kubernetes isn't
isn't assembling or amount or anything.
So how do we configure the static manifest
directory? Could that be put in somewhere else?
We take a look at the kubelet comp.
We can, but at this point, the kubelet
should still be stopped right now.
But we did have an API server and
a oh, yeah. We stopped the. Okay.
So we don't have anything right now. Okay.
Oh, no.
Well, we'll still have any containers that we're
running prior to
stopping the kubelet.
Okay.
Okay. That doesn't configure the thing.
What did I do there? Kubelet dot conf.
I thought that kubelet dot conf had the
static manifest path and stuff in it. Am
I wrong?
No. So there's there that cubelet dot conf
is the
the client configuration
for the cubelet.
There's varlib.
Somewhere in varlib is the actual
bootstrap config for
the cubelet and
the actual configuration.
Okay. So the static pod path as Kubernetes
manifest.
Yeah. So I think we're gonna end up
having to recreate those.
At this point, we can probably just copy
them over from
yes. We could potentially use kubeadm to bring
back the control plane manifest,
or we can just copy them over from
Cluster 09 too.
Okay. Do you know what the kubeadm command
would be?
It's going to be one of the phases.
So it'll be cube a d m
in it, and then there should be phases.
Rawk phase. Rawk phase.
And then
the
control plane one.
Well, we'll probably have to do etcd and
control plane.
And it says, etcd, generate a static pod
manifest for a local etcd.
Local.
Yeah?
Local?
Yep.
And then control plan.
All
and then will we start the kubelet?
Do we still have those directories mounted?
I'm thinking so by how long that took.
Yes.
I think we probably wanna try another unmount
on those.
Okay.
Let's
try one of them and see what happens.
So let's try
if we can get that to work first.
Yeah. Okay. So that looks better.
I've lost my history. Okay. So
mount,
awk,
never
print three.
XRX.
That look okay?
Yep.
And there was a suggestion to use a
lazy on mount.
Do know the flag? I don't wanna delete
my
my text.
I wanna say it was yeah. Dash l.
Okay.
Looks better. Okay.
Okay. So we've now started the Kubelet. We
generated
static manifests with QBDM
and all of it. I always say that
QBDM is cheating for the purposes of this,
but I think that we debugged the problem
and we were just skipping out of the
really boring bit of pasting in YAML. So
I'm okay with it in this instance.
If we run a PSEUX,
do we have a kubelet? We at least
got a kubelet,
but not much else yet. So maybe
give that I mean, look at the kubelet
log, see if there's anything standing out there.
That's here.
No
pager.
That looks a lot healthier. No. Connection refused.
And I expect that if the API server
is not necessarily
up.
Oh, yeah. I think it's coming. There we
go.
Guess we could just follow it.
So
let's go ahead and see
see if we have etcd running, see if
we have the API server running.
API server looks good. Etcd, I've seen earlier.
I think that's alright.
Does
I wonder if the API server is responding
at this point.
It is.
Pods are running.
It's fixed.
Ish.
Ish. I mean, Rawkode and Seth, I wouldn't
expect to be
up so quickly.
But I think we fixed it.
How does our
WordPress deployment look?
Happy and healthy.
Alright.
And just double check cube system as well
just to
be sure.
Running, running, running, running, running.
I mean, I think Rick and Seth will
just need the moment. But
based on, you know, Lewis telling me they
didn't have a lot of time, I think
their
hack was the
Mountie overlay craziness
and that script running in the background doing
whatever the hell that was doing that we
killed, we got the unmount.
I think we did it.
That was that
was quite interesting for sure.
That
that was two really tough clusters. Thank you,
Lewis and Control Plane. Thank you, Thomas.
You definitely put us through our paces there.
Not only did we have to try and
fix
Kubernetes in a multitude of ways, but we
even struggled to keep our debugging tools running
at one point.
Well,
that was a tough one. Thanks, Jason, for
joining me and guiding us through that. You
kept very calm all the way through, which
is
not easy, at least not for me.
No. It's definitely not. There were definitely some
interesting curve balls that were thrown our way
to try to debug. So
Oh, yeah. Definitely.
It was a fun adventure, though. Thank you
for having me.
Alright. Well, thank you to our breakers. Thank
you, Jason, for joining me on Team Fix.
Remember, you can open an issue on the
GitHub page if you wanna join and do
one of these sessions. Thank you all for
watching, and I'll speak to you all again
soon. Thank you.